donc j'aimerais tout d'abord commencé en
reconnaissant que montréal se retrouve
sur un territoire morale traditionnelle
donc de remercier la nation moringue de
nouvelles c'est tenir cet événement
sourire territoire traditionnel et n'ont
cédé la thématique de cet événement est
différente nature puis je pense que je
suis en quelque sorte différentes de
nature depuis ma naissance en fait parce
que j'ai grandi dans deux cultures
complètement différente toute ma vie
donc ma mère et à gond qu'il est mon
père est québécois et je peux vous
garantir que à cause de ça j'ai quand
même fait face à plusieurs défis sa pas
toujours été facile de grandir dans deux
mondes complètement différents mais
finalement je vois vraiment de manière
positive dans son ski ça me permet de
faire le pont entre les différentes
cultures
ça fait plusieurs années que je milite
que je milite pour la cause autochtone
ça fait huit ans que je travaille chez
les femmes autochtones du québec
j'ai été largement impliquée dans la
branche québécoise du mouvement social
autochtone adorno mois récemment j'ai
décidé de co fondé l'organisation mme
cano parce que je trouvais qu'ils
avaient trop mes connaissances sur les
questions autochtones
qu'est ce qui est intéressant c'est que
c'est ces rentes expérience le site ces
initiatives ont eu comme avantage de
remettre les questions autochtones à
l'heure du jour et dernièrement au cours
des dernières années au cours des
derniers mois j'ai eu vraiment une tonne
de personnes qui m'ont approché qui
m'ont posé tellement de questions sur
comment ce qu'il pouvait contribuer à la
cause autochtone
qu'est ce qu'il devait faire pour aider
les autochtones
comment quelle approche est ce qui
devrait avoir et c'est donc pour la
toute première fois j'ai décidé de vous
partager en fait quelques conseils sur
comment est ce que vous pouvez bien
contribuer à la cause et acteur comment
est des bons alliés
c'est la première fois que je vais ce
que je fais ça c'est donc c'est un scoop
et
donc ces dix conseils de commandes
depuis collaboré en fait avec les
autochtones
avant d'aller plus loin et j'aimerais
donc je vois pas très bien mais
j'aimerais savoir à main levée dans la
salle comique de gens ici qui savent
qu'il est combien d'un à son secteur au
québec
je vois pas très bien mais j'en vois pas
beaucoup
combien de personnes ici connaissent la
loi sur les indiens où on entendu parler
combien de gens ici ont déjà entendu
parler du régime des pensionnats et donc
vous avez ou six ont entendu parler de
la commission de vérité et
réconciliation et combien de personnes
s'y seraient capables de nommer un appel
à l'action de la commission de vérité et
réconciliation ok donc en fait c'est
pour faire réaliser tout d'abord
vraiment l'importance de bien connaître
l'histoire des autochtones les réalités
autochtones en fait pour bien contribuer
à la cause parce que souvent quand on
constate des enjeux contemporains
autochtone c'est qu'on voit seulement
les symptômes bien connaître l'histoire
mieux que naquit réalité autochtone ça
ne donne vraiment une bonne base pour
connaître les racines profondes qui
explique la situation actuelle donc pour
vous aider j'ai mis une petite carte les
nations autochtones au québec et au
canada pour qu'elle me rappelle que l'on
sait à son toque tonnes juste ici au
québec je vous invite également à bien
connaître la nation autochtone donc le
territoire de la nation autochtone sur
lequel vous vous trouvez de la région où
est-ce que vous habitez ou de la région
doivent fournir un autre petit conseil
que je donne c'est souvent c'est ne pas
parler au nom des autres acteurs parce
que j'ai en fait un flash back de cangé
2000 tentes dans le mouvement à dos noir
et je me rappelle je zappe et j'écoutais
tve et je sens besson
un panel donc un débat qui se nommait
devrait-on abolir les réserves et ceux
qui interviennent dans des dépôts
c'était richard martineau isabelle
maréchal est un anthropologue
spécialiste des questions autochtones et
je me suis dit oh mon dieu comment
est-ce qu'on peut aborder une question
autochtone aussi crucial sans le
moindrement inclure une personne
autochtone qui puisse exprimer son
opinion
donc ce que ce conseil en fait c'est de
réfléchir à comment est-ce que comment
est ce qu'on peut créer des espaces qui
valorise le leadership qui valorise la
voix des personnes autochtones aussi un
autre conseil aller au delà des bonnes
intentions
malheureusement toute l'histoire de la
colonisation est en fait basée sur des
bonnes intentions les pensionnaires
étaient de bonnes intentions
la loi sur les high tech est une bonne
intention à l'origine et je vois aussi
différentes situations aujourd'hui de
code appropriation culturel porter une
croix une fausse coiffe autochtone de
shakespeare rempli de bonnes intentions
mais ça devrait malheureusement pas
nécessairement les impacts voulu positif
sur les communautés donne donc un
questionnement que j'essaye fait avoir
c'est plutôt est ce que j'avais des
bonnes fêtes en famille plutôt qu'ils
avaient pas positif que mon action
pourrait avoir sur les communautés
autochtones et pour la cause autochtone
autre conseil aller au delà des
alliances de circonstance g soit revue
des situation dans laquelle je me suis
moi même retrouvé et que j'étais en fait
un peu l'autochtone de service et je
peux dire je sais que sa part levé pour
différents groupes
donc c'est une invitation au sida
pousser la réflexion plus loin sur
comment est-ce qu'on peut aller au delà
des alliances ponctuelles comment est-ce
qu'on peut développer des relations plus
durable entre autochtones et non
autochtones et finalement le gellert
peut-être un petit peu de tact orient
mais conseille aussi que je te remercie
en fait c'est correct de faire des
erreurs c'est correct de faire des
gaffes
c'est correct aussi qu'il ya des
incompréhensions les la réconciliation
entre autochtones et non autochtones ne
se fera pas du jour au lendemain ça soit
pas un serment facile il va avoir des
mets compréhension il va avoir des
chèques des échecs de valeur des chèques
de culture ça paraît simple soit on se
tient dans la main on danse et on semble
comme bailleur donc c'est ça va être
parce mais aussi de ma mère quand même
dc et dépassements difficiles mais les
écureuils en fait de faire des gaffes
des erreurs l'important je pensais de
garder son humilité d'apprendre de ses
erreurs de s'excuser éventuellement
commis une gaffe qui est blessé j'ai
blessé quelqu'un puis je pense notamment
aux prix si l'iran quand internationales
du documentaire de montréal l'année
passée qui avait diffusé un documentaire
qui était quand même très offensant pour
le peuple inuit et cette année y ont
fini par reconnaître les temps que c'est
la découvrir et ils y ont décidé de
sortir un communiqué public des excuses
et d'organiser en fait un panel qui
mettait de l'avant
les cinéastes autochtone dans lequel il
pouvait parler de leur propre voie
j'aimerais peut-être présentés tout au
long de mon parcours j'ai quand même
fait face à différentes initiatives
vraiment inspirante en termes de
relations de collaboration entre
autochtones et non autochtones
donc on essaye de me rappeler des
événements qui m'ont marqué spontanément
il y en a deux en fait qui me qui me
sont venus à l'esprit est la première
c'est le protocole de solidarité qui
était signée entre femmes autochtones du
québec et la fédération des femmes du
québec et en fait j'ai vraiment réalisé
que les femmes sont souvent à
l'avant-garde en termes d'amélioration
du relais
entre autres acteurs et non autochtones
et la fédération des femmes du québec en
fait compris qu'elle ne pouvait parler
au nom des femmes autochtones qui ne
pouvait agir ou organiser des programmes
pour les femmes autochtones sans
travailler avec femmes autochtones du
québec qui a été fondée il ya plus de 40
ans qui travaille auprès des femmes
autochtones depuis plus de 40 ans qui
connaît bien la situation les besoins
des femmes autochtones donc en 2004 il
ya une déclaration solennelle de
solidarité d'égal à égal que dessiner
entre la fédération des femmes du québec
et femmes autochtones du québec et c'est
un exemple que je dis souvent une bonne
pratique qui devrait même être utilisé
au niveau politique il ya différentes
échelles et pour terminer un moment au
fait qui m'a vraiment marqué dans tout
mon parcours c'est surtout début je vous
disais que j'avais grandi dans deux
cultures différents le moment au fait
que j'avais réalisé que j'étais
différent
ces quelques mois mon petit frère
ce qu'il y avait d'autres élèves qui
nous appelaient mme horrocks une traité
de morogues de warrior testés n'étaient
pas dit de manière que j'aurais possible
dans cet épais de relatif parce que
c'était une école québécoise avec eux
que moi mon frère on est autochtone dont
j'étais très très jeunes pendant la
crise d'oka mais déjà ça m'affecter
d'une certaine manière puisse aller
crier vraiment des des images qui des
images chocs de tension entre
autochtones et allochtones qui sont
restés dans notre imaginaire collectif
autant côté autochtone que jeune
autochtone piste ou d'image fait partie
aussi de mon imaginaire puis puis quand
je pense je pense justement aux impacts
négatifs que ça l'avait sur les
différentes communautés autochtones à
travers le québec
donc c'est une image aussi eux qui parle
beaucoup d'elle même piqué vraiment
historique de de tension entre
autochtones
de la photo a droit donc la photo à
gauche et en 1990 la photo à droite
c'est en 2013
et c'est au même endroit
ou presque c'est à oka et les morag
d'alcaniz attaquez vous êtes à côté de
okah avait décidé d'organiser une
manifestation pour dénoncer les sables
bitumineux le passage du territoire sauf
communauté donc c'est dans le cadre d'un
appel à l'action nationale qui avaient
été lancées par des groupes écologistes
des groupes militants des mouvements qui
ont répondu et des québécois qui était à
montréal au lieu de rester à montréal
sachant que les mora qui avait déjà
organisé quelque chose ont décidé
d'organiser un autobus et d'aller se
joindre au maroc et d'aller en fait
milité avec eux contre les parfums et
les fables et j'ai trouvé vraiment le
contraste vraiment vraiment inspirant
sachant que c'était sur un lieu où il y
avait un historique important de tension
entre autochtones et québécois et que
maintenant au même lieu
il y avait un groupe de québécois de
différentes origines dumora qui est des
autres acteurs de différentes origines
qui milité ensemble et qu'ils
collaboraient ensemble face à un enjeu
commun et je m'étais dit que finalement
tout le travail que je fais est
finalement c'était pas assister et
participer aussi à des événements et des
moments inspira comme celui-ci
j'aimerais donc terminer finalement à
vous en vous invitant à être vous si
différent de nature à être avant
gardiste remettre en question vous vos
préjugés les informations que vous avez
sur les autres acteurs ou votre approche
en fait que vous avez face aux
autochtones
puis le finalement ne jamais
sous-estimer l'impact rire les positif
que vous pourriez vous aussi avoir dans
l'avenir
des relations entre producteurs et non
autochtones merci beaucoup
big match
[Applaudissements]